George gabriel on drug since Jordan,
please help me.
I'm 99th percentile and openness and zero with percentile and conscientiousness.
Yeah.
Well how old are you?
That's the first thing.
If you're,
if you're young,
that's um,
because younger people are less conscientious.
So that's one thing to keep in mind.
If you're very open like that,
you need to be doing something creative,
but you're going to have to learn how to discipline yourself.
There's just no way around it.
And I would say go do the future authoring program.
That's a good start.
And you'll have to learn how to schedule your time and how to get up at the same
time every day.
And it's going to be a real struggle.
But you know,
you,
you can do it.
I've had students who are very high in openness and low in conscientiousness as
graduate students and they disciplined themselves.
You need to find something that you're really interested in,
that you're willing to pursue and then you have to hit it hard.
Um,
so that's what I would say.
But do the future authoring program and get yourself a plan and start to
implement it.
And every time you fall astray,
then get back at it.
And you know,
you may have to build up your conscientiousness over a number of years and,
but it's worth doing so.